bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans savaugarde ce soir
Bertrand Perrier vient nous parler de
son dernier livre sur les grands
discours qui nous inspirent bonsoir
Bertrand grand plaisir de vous recevoir
comme grand témoin ce soir la parole
pour le meilleur et pour le pire chez la
thèse de sicéron à chat GPT vous nous
invitez à puiser dans les grands
discours qui ont fait date pour devenir
à notre tour de grands orateurs nous
commenterons ensemble plusieurs extraits
de ces fameux célèbres discours tout à
l'heure notre grand débat ce soir la
Nupe est-elle morte l'attaque terroriste
sur Israël par le ramas semble avoir eu
raison de l'alliance de la gauche à
l'Assemblée et pourtant écologiste
communiste et socialiste refusent de la
quitter clairement alors pourquoi y
a-t-il une vie à gauche sans Jean-Luc
Mélenchon nous en débattons dans un tout
petit instant sur ce plateau enfin ns
affranchi ce soir le mot de la semaine
de Mariette dargrand une chronique écho
très rock and roll vous verrez avec
Thomas Lestavel et puis action Planet
avec Léa Falco voilà pour le menu on y
va Bertran Perrier ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
maintenant la chute était prévisible la
guerre au Proche Orient l'a précipité
mais pour autant laanup la coalition de
gauche à l'Assemblée semble bouger
encore l'emprise de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est-elle si grande que les partis
partenaires et colo communistes
socialistes n'arrivent pas à s'en
débarrasser une autre union sans le
leader insoumis est-elle possible on va
essayer de tout comprendre ce soir grâce
à nos invités bonsoir Antoine Oberdorf
ravie de vous retrouver sur ce plateau
vous êtes journaliste politique à
l'opinion et vous êtes en charge du
suivi de la gauche tout comme vous
Mathieu de Jean bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste à médiap
où vous suivez donc laanupe mais aussi
les différents partis national et à
l'Assemblée bonsoir Christelle crappelet
bonsoir ravi de vous accueillir vous
êtes la directrice de BVA opinion enfin
bonsoir Franck Morel bonsoir expert à
l'Institut Montaigne ancien conseiller
d'Édouard Philippe notamment Bertrand
perrier c'est un feuilleton politique
pas simple donc n'hésitez pas si vous
avez besoin d'intervenir à le faire en
interrogeant nos nos invités justement
pour commencer avant de vous donner la
parole le résumé des derniers épisodes
avec Stéphan blackakowski dans son
chrono tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir myiam
alors bonsoir à toutes et tous elle est
morte elle est pas morte écoutez je sais
qu'on s'interroge ce soir sur l'avenir
de l'anupes mais alors autant vous le
dire d'anglais la question n'est pas
nouvelle puisqu'on se l'a posé en fait
dès la création de la nuit P regardez ça
c'était en juin 2020 22 voyez quel
avenir pour la nupes on s'interrogeait
déjà à l'époque c'est parce que jeanluc
mélenchon avait échoué à créer un groupe
parlementaire unique faut dire que ses
alliés communistes colos socialistes se
méfiaent un peu de sa propension à
décider de tout tout seul mais au-delà
de ça ce qui agassait les Alliés c'est
aussi ces positions très souvent
conflictuelles défendu par les insoumis
ça c'était dès le départ vous allez voir
que vous vous souvenez sans doute que
Fabien Roussel avait exigé le retrait de
la candidature de ta bouav qui est un
militant pro palestinien et qui avait
été condamné pour un jeu racial et puis
un mois plus tard c'était Jérôme Gede
qui s'esttou fait lorsque les insoumis
avaient déposé une résolution pour
qualifier Isra de régime d'apartide ça
c'était dans les un mois et demi qui
onit suivi la création bref dès le début
on a vu qu'on se méfie du tempérament de
Mélenchon et de ses positions
conflictuelles on peut donner bien sûr
quelques exemples qui vont vous rappeler
des souvenirs par exemple lorsque adrien
catnins a été condamné pour violence
conjugale des milliers militant gauche
ont réclamé son exclusion hop et bien
l'affaire s'est réglé d'un seul tweet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui lui a renouvelé
sa confiance et du coup bien voyez le
débat était Coulot mais c'était pareil
pour la réforme des retraites alors que
les syndicats une partie de la gauche
voulait éviter cette stratégie
d'obstruction et bien Mélenchon n'en
avait cure d'un seul tweet il a réglé le
problème en décidant que on continuerait
l'obstruction bref même si Mélenchon
n'est pas élu à l'Assemblée il a
tendance à se considérer comme le patron
de la nuupes qui décide de tout à coup
de tuite et forcément ça agace un peu
notamment marine Tondelier je veux pas
non plus qu'on résume la position des
parlementaires nupes à celle de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est pas la présence des
écologistes dans laanupes ou la présence
des socialistes ou des commises en an
pass le problème c'est un des de ces
pseudo leaders qui qui passe son temps à
même à provoquer tout le monde en fait
par des tweets intempestifs je sais pas
qu'il peut lui couper Twitter à un
moment mais voilà est-ce qu'on peut
couper Twitter couper
à jeanl méenchon ça paraît peu
vraisemblable mais ce qui agace aussi
donc ce sont ces positions
conflictuelles on les a vu exprimer dès
le départ ça s prolongé pendant toute
l'existence de
laanupes par exemple le refus d'appeler
au calme pour les émeutes c'est quelque
chose qui a isolé les insoumis au sein
de la gauche et puis encore plus
récemment le refus de considérer le
Hamas comme un mouvement terroriste vous
avez vu que à cette occasion les
insoumis sont mis à dos en quelque sorte
ou en tout cas se sont opposés à
l'opinion de 80 % là c'est le point de
rupture non ah écoutez il me semble que
les points de rupture étaient présents
dès le départ effectivement peut-être
que à ce moment-là ils ont explosé en
tout cas lui Jean-Luc Mélenchon se cache
pas hein il est révolutionnaire la
révolution ça passe par l'insurrection
du coup il faut conflictualiser mais ça
commence à fatiguer un peu tout le monde
he on écoute il y a effectivement une
stratégie posée par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
de tout conflictualiser de faire en
sorte que à tout moment il y ait
toujours un clivage net mais le le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ne
Clive plus seulement la droite par
rapport à la gauche mais il Clive aussi
la gauche et c'est le problème bref
depuis le début on s'interroge sur
l'avenir de la nuupes bien la question
reste d'actualité maintenant que les
écolos ne veulent pas de liste commune
que les communistes et les socialistes
prennent leur distance quel l'avenir
pour la numbes et ben on va essayer de
voir plus clair merci beaucoup Stéphane
on voit que le feu couvait depuis
longtemps hein parce que finalement avec
cette chronique de de Stéphane on se
rend compte que quasiment dès la
naissance il y avait des des grosses
divisions mais depuis le 7 octobre
depuis l'attaque terroriste du ramas sur
Israël contre Israël est-ce qu'il y a un
avant et un après est-ce que on peut
parler de rupture quel mot on met sur
cette crise très violente il y aura
indéiablement en avant et en après on sa
les les les passions irrationnelles que
suscite le conflit seral au Palestiniens
dans la société française c'est quelque
part normal au vu de la forte communauté
juive que nous avons en France première
communauté juive d'Europe et de la forte
présence musulmane dans notre pays euh
il y a eu un un péché originel qui était
celui du communiqué du du 7 octobre qui
n'a pas qualifié en des termes
suffisamment peut-être scrupuleux euh le
Hamas comme un groupe terroriste
islamiste et quelque part tout en a
découlé et ça nous renvoie un malentendu
qu'il y a eu peut-être au moment de la
constitution de laanupes c'est-à-dire
que jamais cet accord électoral a trouvé
à se concrétiser dans un groupe
interparlementaire mais jamais il n'y a
eu d'instance de régulation des conflits
internes à la nupes HM ou une instance
où ils auraient pu formuler en sememble
un propos un communiqué qui donnait la
lecture de laanupes et de la gauche
française sur précisément ce conflit
israopalestinien et toutes les divisions
et qui et les différents qui s'étalent
sur la place publique entre les leaders
de gauche depuis ne sont que la
résultante de ce malentendu initial h
Mathieu dejan est-ce qu'on peut dire que
pour les écologistes pour les
communistes et pour les socialistes
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour les partis
pour leur chef le problème aujourd'hui
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon bah oui
clairement en fait soit il le nomme
directement soit directement mais c'est
vrai que dans leurs communiqués
respectifs on sent bien que c'est à la
fois Jean-Luc Mélenchon et son c'est ses
très proches qui sont concernés qui sont
pointés du Doig pour le mode de
fonctionnement qu'ils ont en fait
interne à la France insoumise d'ailleurs
cette crise ne met pas seulement en
lumière les contradictions de l'anupes
mais aussi celle interne à la France
insoumise moi je dirais quand même que
voilà que par rapport au cette octobre
c'est non seulement effectivement il y
aura un avant un après après pour moi
c'est plutôt une sorte de déclencheur
c'est la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vas parce qu'il y a une
accumulation en fait de choses mais je
dirais pas seulement que c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en fait cette union de la
gauche comme toutes les unions de la
gauche dans l'histoire elle est
contradictoire il y a des forces
modérées des forces radicales en
l'occurrence pour la première fois la
force dominante est radicale ce qui fait
que voilà ça bouge et d'ailleurs dans le
résumé qui a été fait la proposition de
résolution sur la parteille de israélien
ne venait pas de la France insoumise
mais du Parti
communiste voilà et on retient pourtant
que c'est la France Insou parce qu'il y
a quand même un contexte de
diabolisation de cette force comme il
pouvait y avoir une diabolisation du
Parti communiste à l'époque où il était
très fort je reste un petit peu avec les
journalistes qui suivent de de près
voilà les les comment dire ça les
atermoims des uns et des autres à
l'Assemblée qu'est-ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée les écologistes les
communistes continuent à travailler avec
les insommis les socialistes parlent de
moratoire donc ils ne sortent pas
définitivement mais ils ne travaillent
plus comment vous expliquez qu'il reste
déjà c'est une situation assez baroque à
laquelle on assiste à l'Assemblée et
d'ailleurs le le temps qu' a mis quelque
part le président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée Boris valallot pour
clarifier la situation du PS en est
l'illustration c'est-à-dire qu'on a des
députés socialistes qui effectivement
maintenant sont sous un moratoire qui
les empêche de mener un travail en
commun avec leurs alliés et leurs
partenaires de l'anupes ça se
matérialise par des choses très
concrètes hein par le fait que notamment
la motion de censure qui sera présentée
à l'assemblée pourrait ne pas être votée
par les socialistes en tout cas elle ne
ser sera pas rédigé en commun avec leur
partenaire de nupes et c'est vrai que on
comprend bien que la seule instance
véritable qui tenait la nupes qui était
peut-être fonctionnelle jusqu'ici
c'était précisément le groupe
interparlementaire simplement l'ombre de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a pesé de tout son
poids sur le fonctionnement de ce groupe
au point de le rendre aujourd'hui caduc
j'ajouterai juste une chose quand même
c'est que si la raison pour laquelle ils
vont pas jusqu'à briser totalement
l'anupess à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale qui est l'endroit où elle
fonctionnait mieux effectivement c'est
qu'ils sont tous convaincus que l'union
de la gauche est quand même une
condition pour la victoire de la gauche
en en 2027 et donc pour l'instant le
bras de faer qui s'engage c'est de
réformer est-ce que c'est vraiment la
victoire de 2027 qu'il vise où est-ce
qu'ils ne craignent pas la dissolution
et dans ces cas-là tous ces députés bah
si les insoumis leur mettent des des
investitures des candidats ils sont pas
réélus est-ce que c'est pas ça à la
vraie raison non oui je pense qu'ils ont
ces deux scénarios en fa il a
probablement ces deux scénarios mais les
regards sont quand même beaucoup porté
vers 2027 et c'est vrai que la force
motrice que l'on reconnaissait
initialement à Jean-Luc Mélenchon cette
figure tutelaire l'homme des 22 % celui
qui avait réveillé l'espoir à gauche
aujourd'hui certains interrogent son
pouvoir de nuisance mais les regards
sont quand même bien tournés vers 2027
alors Christelle crappel les Français
comment ils regardent ça l'attitude de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur le conflit au
proche- Orient c'est la condamnation
massive oui et son image à jean-l
Mélenchon s'est considérablement dégradé
très récemment donc probablement en lien
avec le conflit nous on a une question
qui demande est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il estit de l'influence à l'avenir on
a plus que 13 % des Français qui nous
répondent oui c'est son plus mauvais
score depuis plusieurs années et en plus
quand on regarde au sein de la gauche il
y a des clivages quand même très très
forts les sympathisants LFI continuent
de lui accorder un fort crédit 79 %
souhait qu'il ait de l'influence mais
c'est moins de 20 % chez les
sympathisants PS chez les sympathisants
ELV qui lui préfèrent largement d'autres
personnalités comme Ruffin Roussel jado
mais son socle on va dire électoral ses
sympathisants n'est pas touché par ce
qui vient de se passer son cœur de cible
est sympathisant à fi continue de lui
accorder quand même du crédit mais dès
qu'on élargit un petit peu aux autres
composantes de laanupes il y a de net
clivag donc on retrouve la même chose
avec les prises de position des des
différents représentants la France un
soumise en terme d'image vos collègues
de dipsos ont fait un un grand travail
fracture française qui montre
qu'aujourd'hui LFI et le parti perçu par
les Français comme le plus dangereux et
donc devant le rassemblement national de
Marine Le Pen vous retrouvez ça vous
aussi tout à fait dès qu'on fait des
enquêtes que ce soit sur la retraite ou
plus récemment sur le terrorisme qu'on
demande la confiance qu'on les Français
dans un certain nombre de par on a
toujours LFI assez bas alors c'est un
peu moins le cas pour les retraites mais
là sur le terrorisme il est très très
bas en terme de confiance et assez loin
du rassemblement national qui quels que
soi les sujets reste le parti dans
lequel finalement le parti d'opposition
qui pour les français donne le plus
confiance même si là aussi c'est
minoritaire on est quand même dans une
classe politique qui est largement
décriée par par la population alors il y
a un coup politique quand même pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à quoi joute-il
Franck Morel quelle est sa stratégie à
qui s'adresse-t-il précisément quand il
refuse de
à un moment donné je crois par Olivier
fort dans sa prise de parole tout à
l'heure c'est la stratégie de la
conflictualisation systématique dans un
certain nombre de cas qui effectivement
est pratiqué de manière récurrente sur
un certain nombre de sujets et donc
cette stratégie de la conflictualisation
vise à permettre d'identifier beaucoup
plus fortement des prises de position et
de de susciter une adhésion à ces prises
de position moi je voudrais mettre en
perspective un peu historique un peu sur
longue durée la situation à laquelle
nous sommes
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui je
voudrais d'abord mettre ça en
perspective historique avec
effectivement ça a été dit tout à
l'heure le le rapport de force au sein
de la gauche et nuancer un quelque chose
que vous avez dit vous avez dit la la
partie radicale de la gauche n'a jamais
été dominante avant c'est faux le Parti
communiste dans les années 60 et 70 a
été dominant Jacques Ducla avait manqué
de de peu le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle en
1969 en qualifiant les deux candidats
restants Alain peer et georgees pompidon
de bonnet blanc et blancbonnet euh et
précisément jusqu'à la rupture de
l'union de la gauche dans les années 70
sous le septonad GIS cardestin et bien
la domination par le porti communiste
était un élément qui était de nature à
empêcher en réalité l'alternance et ce
n'est que quand le rapport de force a
changé au SE ga de la gauche fruit du
Congrès d'épinis effectivement au début
des années 70 que l'alternance a pu se
produire on peut imaginer premier
élément de perspective historique que ce
précédent et cette grille d'analyse peut
produire un impact on le voit bien à
travers les positions de Bernard
casneuve par exemple de Manuel Vals très
récemment encore Qui a parlé justement
de de de champ républicain d'un côté ou
de l'autre du champ républicain et
produit des effets en terme de stratégie
et en terme de capacité à se projeter
dans l'avenir et puis le deuxième point
en perspective historique si on met en
rapport avec deux dates donc première
date je l'évoquais les années 70 deuxème
date c'est l'émergence du Front National
au début des années 80 enfin l'émergence
l'émergence à un niveau important du
Front national vers le milieu des années
80 aux européennes de 80 24 et puis
l'affaire de Dreux en 1983 est-ce que
avec les chiffres que vous avez
mentionné tout à l'heure sur le fait que
je crois que c'était 54 % en dehors de
dangereux pour la démocratie contre 52
pour le RN est-ce que ce ce basculement
est de nature à modifieré bouleverser et
à posé les germes d'un bouleversement de
je dirais du du du brevet de
déshonorabilité je sais pas si c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le qualifier du
mytigeris entre guillemets de la
déshonorabilité qui pourrait êre is du
RN vers les fill la diabolisation ch de
effectivement une conséquence et qui
pourrait avoir des conséquences
politique mais aussi côté RN on l'a vu
avec l'attitude de Marine Le Pen
notamment à l'Assemblée et l'attit la
posture on va dire de recherche
d'orabilité qui se trouve un peu
conforté en creuxou ou la diabolisation
peut être payante électoralement déjà
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez
vous de de sa de sa stratégie réellement
parce que on sent que le coup politique
il est quand même là tout de suite
est-ce qu'il pense qu'il peut gagner des
électeurs en 2027 avec cette stratégie
il y a Jérôme Gedge qui est député
socialiste qui a confié un déjeuner dans
la presse je sais pas si c'était dans
l'opinion dans médiap par j'ai plus le
la source en tête qui explique j'ai j'ai
vu Jean-Luc Mélenchon et il m'a dit
qu'il fallait clivver à tout prix parce
qu'il devait rester au cœur du débat
pour qu'on parle de lui même en malâ
c'est lui qui polarise il y a a y a
enfin je sais pas si tu en conviendras
Mathieu mais il y a un retournement de
l'arc républicain c'est certain mais il
faut quand même s'accorder sur une chose
c'est que dès le départ lorsqu'Olivier
fordig n'est pas signé pour la
bordélisation ils étaient bien contents
bien bien conscient et peut-être content
d'ailleurs que Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
une un personnage politique qui avait
quitté le parti socialiste pour F le
Parti de gauche avec précisément cette
analyse que la gauche devait être
recentrée vers un pôle de radicalité
donc lorsqu'il dit je n'ai pas signé
pour le la bordélisation le bruit et la
fuur était une stratégie depuis le
départ de Jean-Luc Mélenchon pourquoi
pour travailler ce qu'il appelle le 4è
bloc c'est-à-dire les abstentionnistes
de notre pays et en particulier ceux des
quartiers populaires et c'est là qu'on
en vient à la question du conflit on
arrive à savoir déjà si ça prend si si
quelque chose se passe dans ces publes
là ces quartiersl ou pas moi les retours
que j'ai en tout cas dans les derniers
papiers pour essayer de d'objectiver
parce que tout ça ça ravive le procès le
fameux procès en Islam gauchisme donc il
faut se tourner tout simplement vers les
quartiers populaires où il y a une
population issue de l'immigration pour
savoir ce qu'il en la vérité c'est que
peut-être que l'analyse que le conflit
israal aupalestinien et la cause
palestinienne est un levier de
mobilisation électorale peut-être que
cette analyse est portée au sein de la
France insoumise ça je je peux en
convenir mais il n'y a aucune base
électorale pour dire de manière
essentialisée que les population de ces
quartiers répondrai à l'appel de la cte
palestinienne par définition y il y a
une seule chose qui peut objectiver
l'adhésion ou pas au discours de Jean
Mélanchon depuis la présidentielle c'est
les législativs partiels en fait donc
c'est des éléments assez faibles pour
mesurer ça ils ont gagné un député René
Pilato ils ont ils ont perdu Benedict
Torine en Ariège le RN a perdu un député
euh donc ça c'est des éléments en fait
trop trop faibles pour pouvoir mesurer
euh l'impact de la stratégie de Jean a
priori maintenant pour vous ça n'est pas
payant cette straté pour autant euh on
peut enfin voilà il y a il y a quand
même toujours eu la volonté à la France
insoumise de se rattacher aux classes
populaires euh d'où euh le discours
qu'ils ont eu au moment euh des révoltes
urbaines euh d'où le fait qu'aujourd'hui
euh il tentent de ne pas lâcher la la la
cause voilà des associations
propalestiniennes euh en tout cas ce qu'
peut expliquer aussi l'attitude de
Jean-Luc Mélanchon en plus de sa
stratégie d'aller chercher le 4e bloc
c'est que euh cette stratégie de la
conflictualité qui finalement a mis
laanupes complètement euh sous tension
c'est euh à l'époque hein c'est une
philosh d'illeurs il reprend beaucoup
cette stratégie du populisme de gauche
dans son dernier livre faites mieux euh
en fait c'est aussi que il sait qu'il ne
ne pourra pas être de nouveau le
candidat de l'Union de la gauche enfin
pourra pas être le candidat de
l'anupesse ni les écologistes ni les
socialistes ni les communistes ne sont
prêt à ce que de nouveau il reprenne le
le flambeau pour la 4e fois donc comme
Fabien Roussel d'ailleurs qui lui aussi
a des ambitions pour la présidentielle
de 2027 il la il la brise quelque part
bertrin perriier une question peut-être
une r Je suis pas du tout un expert mais
avec un petit peu de recul est-ce qu'on
peut pas se dire que l'anomalie c'était
la nupes en réalité les trois forces qui
la constituaient n'avaient rien à se
dire et c'était un accord purement
électoral opportuniste pour éviter la
débla qui qui s'annonçait mais ça fait
très longtemps que l'on sait que sur la
laïcité sur le travail sur l'écologie C
trois partis et sur l'EUR en plus qui
s'annonce ces trois partis n'ont pas
grandchose en commun et finalement
peut-être que l'anomalie c'était la
nuupess et qu'on en revient à une
situation classique encore une fois je
suis pas du tout un
spécialist il y a quand même le retour à
une situation presque normal je suis
assez d'accord avec votre réaction
effectivement on peut regarder un peu en
arrière et se dire finalement mais bon
sens c'est même un miracle que ça ait pu
effectivement fonctionner un temps
compte tenu de de l'ampleur des des
divergences après moi je voudrais
revenir sur la stratégie de la
conflictualisation que qui a été évoquée
à à plusieurs reprises la stratégie de
la conflictualisation moi je la
distingrait de la stratégie de du
caractère parfois disruptif de de
d'aller parfois chercher des positions
disruptives je voudrais faire un
parallèle avec la campagne électorale
présidentielle par exemple de 2007 quand
Nicolas Sarkozy était allé proposer à
l'époque la création d'un ministère de
l'Identité nationale cétait quelque
chose à l'époque qui avait été présenté
comme étant extrêmement disruptif et de
nature à créé du clivage et donc pour
lequel on pourrait faire un parallèle
avec ces stratégies de la
conflictualisation sauf qu'en même temps
d'une part c'était quelque chose qui à
l'époque pouvait correspondre à une
attente assez forte d'une segment de
l'électorat contestable mais en tout cas
qui pouvait être analysé comme tel et
que d'autre part par ailleurs il avait
envoyé des signaux par exemple en
faisant référence à jores en faisant
référence effectivement à une partie de
l'histoire de de la gauche euh dans
l'autre sens et donc cette stratégie de
du caractère un peu disruptif d'aller
chercher des positions euh qui qui
peuvent créer du clivage elle ne peut
fonctionner que lorsqu'elle n'est pas
systématique à sens unique sur des
segments électorats électoraux très
restreints et ne s'accompagne pas par
ailleurs d'une volonté d'avoir une
certaine marge d'ouverture pour éviter
justement la rupture avec une autre
partie deélectorat oui la question c'est
les les alliances après le le second
tour un éventuel second tour Christel
crapl pour pour bien comprendre qui sont
les électeurs de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
on dit que la jeunesse vote LFI est-ce
que ça vous le vrai enfin on a plus de
jeunes qui votent LFI mais en déduire
que la jeunesse vote les filles on ne
peut pas parce qu'il y a aussi des
jeunes qui votent RN il y a aussi des
jeunes qui vent Macron il y a surtout
beaucoup de jeunes qui s'abstiennent
donc voilà pareil pour les classes
populaires il y a effectivement des
employés des ouvriers qui votent pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais aussi beaucoup
pour le rassemblement national et la
stratégie de la conflictualité pour
l'instant nous voit pas émerger dans
l'opinion quelque chose en faveur de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur cette Basel on a
plutôt l'impression comme vous le disiez
que ça fait fuir un peu les électeurs
MPS ou ELV sans vraiment gagner beaucoup
de points je regardais par exemple ceux
qui se disent qui ne sont proches
d'aucun parti ceux qui sont très
éloignés de la vie politique ils ont une
image aussi très négative de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors je vous propose
d'avancer un un petit mot rapidement
juste ajouter un mot effectivement sur
cette question de savoir si laanupess
était une anomalie ou pas à mon avis
c'est pas une anomalie l'anomalie c'est
c'est la dérive social libérale du Parti
socialiste depuis voilà toute l'air
Hollande et ce qui s'est passé en 2022
c'est que de manière assez surprenante
effectivement euh alors qu'au début
d'ailleurs la France insoumise s'était
adressé par exemple au NPA mais pas au
Parti socialiste et a fini par le faire
rattraper ensuite par Olivier fort le
Parti socialiste lui a fait un mouvement
davantage vers la gauche et ce qu'on
observe au niveau des votes à
l'Assemblée nationale depuis que l'anupè
existe c'est que leur votes convergent
majoritairement très majoritairement
demand d'ion estès a pris position dans
miaap dans Mia part contre la 69 et se
dit pour le socialisme écologique donc
il y a quand même des convergences entre
ces forces alors on avance on va se
poser la question du fonctionnement de
la France insoumise ici même à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque nous
sommes à LCP est-ce qu'une cission au
sein d'elfi est possible en tous les cas
certains ouis ne laissent ne tessent
plus du tout le leur désaccord regardez
c'est un sujet d'
[Musique]
monagava il est bien loin le temps de
l'arrivée triomphale à l'Assemblée
autour du chef sourire et point levé
aujourd'hui chez les insoumis la crise
est ouverte quand Mathilde Panau la
présidente du groupe ne veut pas
qualifier le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste c'est une la branche armée
qui aujourd'hui est responsable de crime
de guerre voilà et bien j'ai répondu sur
terrorisme vous vous si si vous vous
contenterez de ma de de ma réponse sur
cette question double langage non je
n'ai pas de double langage monsieur et
je ne vous permets pas
de s'arrêter là
François Ruffin lui répond le soir même
dans le monde pas de pudeur de gazelle
ce qui se conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement samedi le Hamas a commis des
abominations on doit mettre des mots
forts sur des actes horribles sinon
notre parole est discrédité puis il y a
cette interview de Daniel obonau
toujours sur le Hamas c'est un groupe
politique islamiste qui a une branche
armée et qui s'inscrit dans les
formations politiques palestiniennes qui
euh a pour objectif la libération de de
la Palestine et qui résiste à une occup
c'est un mouvement de résistance oui une
grande partie du groupe est embarrassé
mais chez les insoumis on ne se
désolidarise pas on ne s'excuse pas tout
juste corrigeet-on au détour d'une
phrase nous n'apportons aucun soutien au
Hamas qui n'est pas un mouvement de
résistance à la France insoumise deux
clans semblent se dessiner d'un côté
ceux qui veulent s'affranchir de
Mélenchon Clémentine Autin François
Ruffin Raquel garidau et Alexis Corbière
et de l'autre sa garde rapproché manuel
bonpard et Mathilde Panau ces derniers
pousseraient les frondeurs au départ si
je voudrais très clair je n'accepterai
que personne mette en cause ma qualité
d'insoumise et je n'accepte pas les
appels à ce que nous partions ou que
sais-je ce n'est pas par des coup de
butoir et et des appels disciplinaires
euh ou excluant que les les les
difficultés qui sont celles de la France
insoumises seront réglées alors dans la
famille insoumise qui osera un jour tuer
le
père Antoine oberdof ces quatrel Raquel
garidau Alexis corbierre Clémentine tin
François Ruffin peuvent-ils rester
encore longtemps en frondeur au sein de
l'anupe ou là encore une cission d'une
certaine façon est inévitable c'est
toute la question vont-ils sortir du
bois et c'est c'est un assez révélateur
de voir François Ruffin citer Boisot en
disant ce qui ce conçoit bien s'énonce
clairement et les choses pour le dire
viennent aisément depuis le début de
cette séquence François Ruffin est en
surplomb il arrive à tenir les debouts
quelque part et tenir les debouts c'est
assumer la complexité qui est de dire le
Hamas est un groupe terroriste islamiste
qui commet aujourd'hui des atrocités qui
y compris se retourne quand le le peuple
palestinien et le sort des otages
israéliens n'est pas plus enviable et et
ça c'est en cela que François Ruffin au
cours de cette séquence est est en
surplomb maintenant mais on a
l'impression qu'en fait personne ne veut
porter le chapeau de de celui qui quitte
comme si partir serait vu par les
Français ou par les électeurs comme déjà
quelque chose de de pénalisant mais si
c'est des convictions il faut il faut
loyal voir même loyal peut-être parce
qu'ils ont ils savent et ça c'est ce qui
les distinguent les uns des autres en
fonction de leur profil ils savent
qu'ils ont une forme de dette une forme
de dette électorale aussi envers
Jean-Luc mélch en fonction des
circonscriptions dans lesquelles ils ont
été investis en fonction aussi de leur
passé dans le mouvement insoumis qui
était avant le Parti de Gauche c'est ce
qui se pose pourel G on le voit bien
avec Raquel garido je suis insoumise
pour toujours et c'est ma famille après
tout c'est pas mon problème c'est c'est
Mélenchon je pense on est vraiment
effectivement à l'aube d'une bataille au
sein même de la France insoumise qui a
déjà commencé depuis décembre 2022 où il
y avait eu cette assemblée
représentative qui est l'équivalent du
congrès de la France insoumise où le
coordinateur national Manu B est arrivé
de manière un peu mystérieuse nommé
comme ça par cooptation l'ensemble des
dirigeants de de cette coordination des
espaces voilà c'est fait au consensus
donc il y a pas trop de transparence on
se rend compte que c'est des proches de
jeanlilleurs PR qui sont les liutenant
pour bien comprendre on voyait manuel BP
onit ma les personnes qui d'ailleurs
vont à l'intergroupe représenter la
France Insou jusqu'à présent manuel
béid par méchon de l'extérieur est guidé
mais c'est vrai que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aurait pu être un passeur depuis la
présidentielle de 2022 il ne l'a pas été
il a dit faites mieux le soir du premier
tour et finalement il n'a pas transmis
il a dit qu'il se mettait en retraite
pas en retraite en fait il est encore
présent dans la boucle télégram du du
groupe parlementaire de la France mais
ça fonctionne comment ce par on entend
dire que c'est
caporalisé bah c'est en fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il a son poids médiatique il a
Twitter effectivement pendant le débat
sur la réforme des retraite par exemple
il est intervenu en en insultant un
petit peu le groupe communiste qui
voulait retirer ses amendements lui
demandant s'ils avaient hâte de perdre
en fait il a cette force de de frappe
médiatique et politique et des facto en
fait il ne s'appartient plus en fait il
le dit lui-même parfois dans ses
meetings il dit si je suis la seule
personne qui montait dans un train et
qui n'arrive plus à en descendre
et je voudrais revenir sur le fond parce
qu'effectivement il faut revenir aussi
aux thèmes qui ont généré les désaccords
qui sont mis en lumière et c'est
important de de d'y faire référence
parce que c'est quelque chose d'assez
sans doute structurantour
israëlopalestinien le rapport à
l'antisémitisme mais je vais même aller
plus loin le rapport à la laïcité et
même encore le rapport à la police à la
sécurité on on voit bien à travers ces
quatre grandes familles de sujet un
clivage très structurant très profond
qui est peut-être de même nature que un
autre clivage qui a créé de grands
bouleversements dans dans l'organisation
des des des forces politiques entre
elles qui était le clivage européen qui
était beaucoup plus qui traversait
beaucoup plus là c'est un clivage qui
est plus concentré à la gauche de la
gauche mais on le voit bien c'est
important de d'aussi relier ça aux
questions de fond qui sont derrière et
qui peuvent être de nature sans doute
aussi à structurer le débat public dans
les années à venir Christelle crablet
l'alliance c'est avant tout quand même
un accord électoral ici à l'Assemblée
nationale pour les législatives et
pourtant pour le prochain scrutin les
européen bah tout le monde va dans son
coin chacun de de son côté pourquoi
c'est c'est pas le même mode de scrutin
quand on regarde les sondages on se rend
compte que et ben là ils ont tous
intérêt s'ils veulent maximiser leur
nombre d'élus au Parlement de Bruxelles
à à ne pas faire l'alliance oui puis
c'est ce qu' souhaite aussi on leur a
posé la question à part là encore les
sympathisants et les filles qui
voulaient une liste unique les
sympathisants LV les sympathisants PS
ils veulent pas une liste unique ils
veulent leur leur leur propre liste et
puis sur le sujet comme l'Europe c'est
vrai qu'ils sont pas non plus totalement
en accord donc sur un scrutin comme les
européennes en plus c'est là où LV fait
s meilleurs scores on peut comprendre
voilà c'est surtout les écologistes les
socialistes pe ont intérêt aussi bah en
tout cas les sympathisants PS souhaitent
qu'il y ait une liste autonomie et je
pense que là les positions de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur l'Europe vont à
l'encontre de ce que pensent un grand
nombre de sympathisants PS sur notre sur
ce sujet de l'Europe en fait ce qui est
compliqué c'est de comprendre à quoi
sert cette alliance on a compris au
législative il y a un très gros groupe
de de députés de laanup et les
écologistes les les socialistes
particulièrement les communistes ont
sauvé un peu leur peau mais pour la
suite mis à part la la présidentielle
pour les scrutins il y a les européennes
il va y avoir les municipales les
régionales là encore est-ce qu'elle est
utile cette alliance politiquement il
n'y a pas que enfin moi je voudrais dire
quand même qu'il n'y a pas que de la
tactique électorale là-dedans
c'est-à-dire que on a tendance à
effectivement à penser que la politique
s'abaisse à des des stratégies
électorales permanentes en vérité est
qu'on voulu aussi un bon nombre de
personnalités de gauche et écologiste
c'est conjurer et c'est un peu ce que
vous décriviez les la thèse des gauches
irréconciliiables promu par Manuel bals
ça c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
déterminant si on prend simplement la
question Israël au palestinienne il y a
des bornes historiques
67 72 avec les Jeux Olympiques et cet
attentat commis à Munich où la gauche se
déchire sur la question de savoir est-ce
que la cause palestinienne peut tout
justifier est-ce que la fin justifie les
moyens qu'on ne peut pas faire d'omelett
sans casser des œufs et que quelque part
les victimes collatérales comp peu tant
qu'on fait avancer la cause c'est
véritablement sur la question européenne
sur la question les questions
international c'était le grand enjeu de
de certains députés de gauche et
écologiste que de conjurer la tessse des
gauchesréconciliaable ils yons cru
sincèrement simplement et ça fait écho à
une conversation que j'avais récemment
avec une députée écologiste qui pensait
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon allait s'inscrire
dans cette mission de passeur de de
transmission faites mieux sauf que
lorsque vais voir Mélenchon il me dit
que me dit-il il me dit mais lorsque
François mitteran avait désigné un
successeur en la personne de Laurent
fabus au final ce n'est pas lui qui n'a
été retenu et donc quelque part la
transmission ne fonctionne jamais on
lâche jamais en politique pourquoi il
lâche pas
franchement poser la question
alors en tout cas ce que que je peux
dire quand même sur l'utilité de
l'anupes du point de vue des personnes
qui défendent l'union de la gauche c'est
de démontrer qu'ils sont capables de
gouverner ensemble ils savent que ils ne
peuvent pas gagner l'élection
présidentielle qui est l'élection
majeure de la 5e République sans se sans
s'allier donc l'objectif de l'anupes
c'était de créer une culture politique
commune et de travailler sur le
programme pour réussir à se mettre
d'accord le problème c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et la France enensousmis ont
cru que le fait de signer un accord
programmatique de 650 mesures réglait
des toujours dernière petite question
pour terminer ce ce débat un
rassemblement de la gauche sans-jean-luc
Mélenchon de Ruffin à Caseneuve ça c'est
ce que souhaite Fabien Roussel du Parti
communiste en gros une nup enans
Mélenchon est-ce que c'est possible qui
veut répondre c'est c'est honnêtement
assez improbable et et d'cin nous disent
et ça c'est valable dans les quatre
composantes de la nues que ça serait se
mettre dans les mains de leurs
adversaires politiques on voit à l'écran
l'image de Fabien Roussel doquins disent
qu'en cherchant à se recentrer la gauche
va y perdre et que elle va quelque part
réaliser le rêve de leurs adversaires
politiques à savoir être dirigé par
Fabien Roussel qui dont on n'est pas sûr
finalement qu'au-delà de sa code de
popularité il emmène les électeurs de
gauche très rapidement je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que vous venez de dire
et j'ajouterai que il sera intéressant
de voir quel sera le rapport de force
issu des élections européennes pour
regard effement ce qui en ressort est de
nature à rebatt les cartes et notamment
en terme de mouvement dominant du
côtéppel dans l'opinion aucune
personnalité à gauche
n'émerge Fran Ruffin tester à combien il
est alors sa côe d'influence qui est
intéressant surtout c'est de voir qu'il
est numéro 2 chez les sympathisants LFI
et il est dans le top 10 des
sympathisants PS et ELV donc c'est une
personnalité qui réunit au moins les
trois camp bon on verra çaou dernier mot
pour mon avis impossible cette alliance
qui va jusqu'à Bernard parce que
benmarque9 n'a pas fait son
agjournamento idéologique notamment sur
l'écologie et cetera et Françis Ruffin a
beau avoir modéré son discours et
aujourd'hui apparaître comme plus gentil
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur le fond il
n'a pas changé un petit Paris pour
terminer le mot de la fin Mélenchon sera
candidat allez mouillez-vous en 2027 oui
ou non c'est juste un mot j'en suis
convaincu et vous Mathieu Mathieu dejan
Joker là je allez Joker merci allez on
s'arrête là merci c'était très très
riche on a on a mieux compris
personnellement j'ai j vois beaucoup
plus clair vous restez avec moi Bertrand
Perrier dans une dizaine de minutes les
parties prix de nos affranchis le mot de
la semaine de Mariette dariggrand c'est
ce vendredi le mot otage une chronique
écho tout en musique avec Thomas
Lestavel et puis la Falco de quoi nous
parlez-vous cette semaine dans Action
planè pas de panique mais cette semaine
on va parler de directive européenne sur
la comptabilité oui pas de panique en
effet à tout de suite les amis mais
d'abord Bertrand Perrier on va plonger
avec vous dans les grands discours de
notre histoire Martin Luther King André
merau mais aussi éedouard Berg Gret
tberg la parole pour le meilleur et pour
le pire de Cicéron à chat GPT on va s'en
inspirer avec vous juste après
l'invitation Stéphanie des piierre avec
Marco
Pomier si on vous invite Bertrand
perrier c'est parce que vous publiez une
antologie éclectique et personnelle des
meilleurs discours de l'Antiquité à nos
jours avocat professeur d'éloquence
l'art de la rhtorique n'a pas de secret
pour vous et vous aimez le partager
votre dernier livre est un manuel pour
apprendre à captiver son auditoire les
25 discours choisis sont autant de
modèles pour l'art des formules votre
référence c'est Jacques Chirac notre
maison
brûle et nous regardons
ailleurs nous ne pourrons pas dire que
nous ne savions pas pour mobiliser une F
ch le si célèbre Martin Luther
[Applaudissements]
King Bertrand Perrier vous décortier
chaque discours sa construction ses
figures de style vous expliquer pourquoi
ça marche et don des conseils au
lecteurs pour réussir ses propres
discours par exemple mettre son vécu au
service d'une cause comme Robert
Badinter le grand avocat devenu le
ministre qui fait abolir la peine de
mort puisque vous avez prononcé tout à
l'heure le nom de deux condamnés à mort
et de deux exécutés je vous dirai
pourquoi est-ce que plus qu'aucun autre
je sais qu'il n'y a pas dans la peine de
mort de valeur dissuasive autre modèle
d'éloquence l'écologiste grber qui s'est
transformé sa colère en discours devant
l'U Dansette ép va très vite où la
concision est reine ou le zapping est
roi dites-nous Bertrand Perrier quelle
est la recette d'un discours qui fait
date réponse Bertran perriier la recette
d'un discours qui fait date c'est la
rencontre entre un grand sujet et un
grand orateur il faut un sujet très
clivant il faut un sujet très important
on fait pas un grand discours sur un
taux de TVA c'est compliqué il faut
quelque chose qui engage l'avenir et
puis il faut un grand orateur et pour
moi un grand orateur c'est quelqu'un qui
accepte d'être différent qui accepte
d'être lui-même qui accepte d'avoir un
style d'avoir sa propre musique celle
qu'on reconnaît immédiatement et qui est
différente de tous les autres alors
comment il est né ce projet il faut
expliquer que c'est un véritable mode
d'emploi de l'art oratoire que vous
proposez avec ce livre vous avez les
discours qui sont retranscrits il y a à
chaque fois un point de contexte et puis
deux questions comment ça marche et
pourquoi ça marche pourquoi ce projet
alors le projet c'était de faire à la
fois une antologie et un guide pratique
une antologie parce que on aime bien ça
fait partie de notre notre patrimoine
ces grands discours que l'on aime relire
retrouver je les ai rassemblé avec une
part de subjectivité il y en a qui man
la sélection qu'est-ce qu'elle
représente alors elle représente mes
coups de cœur mais il manque plein de
choses il manque de Gaul enfin il y a
plein de choses qui manquent mais je
voulais absolument mettre Édouard Bert
parce que c'est formidable je voulais
mettre Kerry James je ne voulais pas
mettre que de la politique je voulais
mettre aussi des discours de cinéma
enfin c'est aussi ma sélection et puis
il y avait le côté guide pratique
c'estàdire qu'est-ce que ces grands
discours nous apprennent aujourd'hui et
indépendamment des rubriqu pourquoi ça
marche et comment ça marche il y a une
dernière rubrique qui s'appelle à
refaire chez vous vra qui est qu'est-ce
que je peux faire moi quand j'ai besoin
de motiver mon équipe de remercier
quelqu'un de faire un discours de
mariage peut-être pour m'inspirer de ces
25 grands discours alors on y va sur vos
coup de cœur i have a dream on
réentendait Martin Luther King le
discours de Washington
1963 c'est celui dont il faut s'inspirer
si l'on veut faire triompher une idée
l'anaphore ça marche toujours alors il y
a l'anaphore il y a aussi l'incarnation
hein il dit mes petits enfants donc il y
a quelque chose de très illustré de très
incarné ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
l'histoire aussi de ce discours puisque
la formule i have a dream n'est pas dans
le texte de Martin Luther en réalité
c'est au cours du discours que il se
souvient qu'il a déjà employé cette
image et qu'il va improviser et donc on
sait tous que l'improvisation c'est
vraiment la reine de la parole bien sûr
lire un texte c'est important parfois
mais quand on s'en évade c'est en encore
plus vivant et et et habité aucune femme
ne recour de gêé de cœur à l'avortement
Simone veille 1974 à la tribune de
l'Assemblée national ça c'est un
discours pour tenir bon face à un public
hostile oui lorsque Simon veille prend
la parole elle est face à neu femmes et
près de 500 hommes et donc elle est face
à un public hostile et elle va dire
elle-même à quel point cette discussion
parlementaire va être dure elle va subir
des colibets des insultes de Chartier de
la part de députés qui vont la siffler
il y a des gens sur la placeage du
Palais Bourbon qui l'attendent en priant
pour la conspuer donc c'est vraiment
très dur et elle arrive en prenant très
intelligemment la chose peut-être par un
petit bout qui est le bout le plus
médical et non pas le principe des
droits des femmes mais elle dit au moins
que les femmes puissent garder leur
capacité à procréer et que donc les
feuseuses d'anges disparaissent au
profit d'un encadrement de l'IVG h HM et
la question de santé publique va finir
par réussir àou à faire voter si elle
avait parlé du droit des femmes sur leur
corps peut-être que beaucoup de députés
auraient été vexés auraient été piqués
et ils n'auraient pas voté et donc pour
nous tous qui parfois avons à convaincre
une foule hostile est-ce que c'est mieux
finalement d'être dans les principes
mais d'encourir un rejet ou d'être
plutôt dans le pragmatisme et d'obtenir
le vote que l'on souhaite 1981 discours
de l'abolition Robert Badinter devenu
garde des excelle véritablement dans la
manière de reprendre sa robe d'avocat
dans l'hémicycle en plaidant non pas
pour convaincre les députés puisque la
cause est acquise miteron a été élu il a
une large majorité mais pour convaincre
les Français oui parce que là il y a
au-delà de l'Assemblée nationale au-delà
des murs du palais Bourbon une opinion
qui est majoritairement hostile à la
peine de mort ce qui est formidable
c'est la porosité entre l'avocat et le
ministre il a défendu buffet bon temps
sur la question question précisément de
la peine de mort Patrick Henry et donc
toute cette expérience qu'il a glané
dans ses procès d'assise et bien il la
met au service de ce discours magnifique
est une sorte de pldoirie même si il dit
que ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas
parce que le contexte ne le permet pas
mais et puis il y a ces formules on
parlait de Jack shirac tout à l'heure
dans dans le sujet mais il y a aussi
demain grâce à vous la justice française
ne sera plus une justice qui tue c'est
absolument cette capacité aussi à
trouver la formule ch le choc et puis il
y a aussi 2003 la tribune de l'ONU
Dominique de Villepin et ce discours qui
raisonne avec l'actualité au
ProcheOrient aujourd'hui on va l'écouter
dans ce temple des Nations Unies nous
sommes les gardiens d'un idéal nous
sommes les gardien d'une conscience la
lourde responsabilité et l'immense
honneur qui sont les nôtres doivent nous
conduire à donner la priorité au
désarmement dans la paix et c'est un
vieux pays la France d'un vieux
continent comme le mien l'Europe qui
vous le dit aujourd'hui qui a connu les
guerres
l'occupation la
barbarie un pays qui n'oublie pas et qui
sait tout ce qu'il doit au combattants
de la liberté venu d'Amérique et
d'ailleurs pourquoi ça marche ça ça
marche parce que précisément Dominique
de Villepin l'explique dans un débat
dooc de LCP c'est pas la publicité pour
votre chaîne mais vraiment il explique
comment il rédige ce discours il fait
rédiger une première version qui est
assez technique dont il est pas très
satisfait il y a beaucoup de gens qui
dans les cabinets ministériels
contribuent on le voit dans
kedors la BD bien connue et puis à la
fin il manque une incarnation il manque
de la chair et là il ajoute c'est
quelqu'un qui vient d'un vieux pays la
France qui a trop fait la guerre pour ne
pas savoir elle est souvent nuisible et
ça dans nos prises de parole c'est très
important aussi la technique c'est une
chose mais l'incarnation la sincérité
l'authentité qui je suis pour dire cela
et c'est ce qui fait que le discours de
Dominique de Villepin décolle à la toute
fin après des choses très sérieuses sur
les désarmement sur la crise en Irak
mais à la fin il y a ce petit supplément
d'âme qui fait que le discours devient
un grand discours j'aimerais qu'on
prenne encore quelques exemples dans le
livre pour déconstruire les stéréotypes
vous choisissez le disc cours de
shimamanda and gozi adishi qui est-elle
et pourquoi elle alors c'est une
écrivaine nigériane qui a fait un TEDx
qui a eu énormément de succès qui a été
viral sur les réseaux sociaux notamment
sur Youtube où elle est en quelque sorte
la tête de pont d'un d'un féminisme
heureux un féminisme qu'elle porte entre
hommes et femmes qui n'exclut ni les uns
ni les autres et elle explique que dans
son pays bien la cause des femmes était
particulièrement difficile que elle-même
a dû se battre pour arriver à écrire à
être publié et son manifeste a été
distribué dans des classes en Suède par
exemple toutes les personnes en classe
de de lycée ont reçu ce livre et donc
voilà c'est c'est aussi la la la
capacité à la sincérité du combat et de
dire d'où je viens h enfin carie James
vous en parliez vous avez une relation
particulière racontez-nous il y a
d'abord une rencontre un film une pièce
non d'abord une chanson banliezard
puis une pièce de théâtre et enfin un
film de ciné j'ai rencontré carry James
dans le cadre d'un programme qui
s'appelle eloquancia dans lequel
j'enseigne avec plein d'autres la prise
de parole en public en scène Saint-Denis
et carry James avait accepté de faire
jury d'une finale avec Edward ber et
quelques autres et c'est la finale qu'
l'on voit dans le documentaire à voix
haute et j'avais rencontré carry James à
cette occasion je dois dire humblement
que je ne savais pas qui non je savais
pas qui il était mais on a assez vite
sympathisé et puis euh il a fait un film
qui s'appelle banlieuzard dans lequel il
m'a donné un petit rôle il y a
d'ailleurs un banlieuzard 2 qui vient de
de de sortir et ce qui me frappait dans
ce film banlieusard 1 c'est qu'il a une
joute oratoire de 10 minutes dans ce
film c'est quand même extraordinaire un
moment d'éloquence dans une fiction et
un vrai long moment d'éloquence sur un
sujet passionnant qui est au cœur de la
réflexion de Carry James qui est l'État
est-il seul responsable de la situation
des banlieux en France et parfois les
concours d'éloquances donnent lieu à une
parole un peu esthétique un peu veine un
peu sophiste et là au contraire on a
dans l'affrontement des deux candidats
du film quelque chose de très profond et
très sincère et je renvoie également
donc donc au film j'aimerais terminer
cette interview par un discours qui
n'est pas dans votre livre je voudrais
qu'on l'entende il aimit Julien GRAC
Flobert sttindal et Balzac il aimet
Shakespeare racine et béquett il aimet
les les étanss les rivières et les
fleurs il n'aimait pas les réseaux
sociaux le téléphone il n'en avait pas
écoutez la suite il n'aimait pas la
foule ni les honneurs les cérémonies
qu'il avait en
horreur sensible et
discret il n'aimait pas le bruit et la
fureur du monde il aimait
profondément ses
filles sa mère et sa sœur
nous nous
aimions voilà ça donne la chair de poule
c'était hier Isabelle Bernard l'épouse
de Dominique Bernard assassiné à haras
on peut que s'incliner devant l'émotion
qui affleur à chaque mot et la justesse
du propos c'est ça qui est magnifique et
en même temps bouleversant c'est
l'anaphore il aimait il aimait qui
rythme et qui scande et puis au-delà de
ça l'incarnation la justesse au plus
près et à la fin nous nous aimions et ce
basculement entre il aimait et nous nous
des Mion est évidemment bouleversant
merci beaucoup merci Bertrand Perrier la
parole pour le meilleur et pour le pire
c'est-àdire chez lates on n' pas parlé
de chat GPT on aurait pu on aurait pu
dans une prochaine chronique peut-être
parce que vous le savez évidemment
Bertrand est d'ordinaire chroniqueur le
vendredi et il va retrouver maintenant
sa complice Mariette darigrand ainsi que
Thomas Lestavel ns a franchi leur partie
prix tout de
suite bonsoir Thomas Lestavel pour
l'économie Mariette darigrand le mot de
la semaine installez-vous on commence
comme chaque soir par action planète
bonsoir Léa bonsoir merci d'être là vous
nous parlez ce soir d'une directive
européenne sur la comptabilité kzako oui
alors la CSRD en anglais attention les
oreilles corporate sustainability
reporting directive qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est un ensemble de nouveaux standards
de comptabilité alors dit comme ça ça
fait un petit peu peur mais en fait
c'est fondamental pour la compréhension
de nos sociétés et de la manière dont
elles vont devoir muter parce que la
comptabilité c'est la grammaire de notre
économie alors aujourd'hui vous comme
moi on vit dans un système économique
capitaliste ça veut dire que ce qui
compte c'est ce qu'on compte et
aujourd'hui on ne compte que les impacts
financiers du monde économique sont
laisser complètement de côté les impacts
extra financiers et notamment les
impacts sur l'environnement en gros ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui si vous
détruisez des milieux naturels ou
polluez des rivières pour votre Activ
ité professionnelle vous n'avez pas à en
rendre compte bien sûr ce que fait cette
directive c'est qu'elle transforme un
petit peu ce mode de comptabilité et
qu'elle demande aux 50000 plus grandes
entreprises européennes de fournir deux
types d'analysees une analyse de leur
impact positif ou négatif sur
l'environnement et une analyse de la
vulnérabilité de leur performance
financière face aux crises
environnementales c'est pas un prod du
miracle mais c'est un premier pas dans
la bonne direction et c'est un standard
européen on aurait pu imaginer un
standard mondiale ça n'est pas le cas
alors comment ça va se passer bah c'est
là que ça se corse un petit peu parce
que c'est une bataille d'influence le
standard qui sera le standard gagnant
pourra déterminer ce que sont les
critères de durabilité appliqués à
quasiment toutes les grandes entreprises
de la planète et aujourd'hui vous avez
deux standards principaux le standard
européen dont je viens de vous parler et
le standard américain qui est moins
complet qui ne demande qu'une analyse
sur la vulnérabilité et qui donc on peut
le dire Mo conséquent quand que
l'Européen décevant est le mot que moi
j'aurais employé effectivement et donc
c'est un Français d'ailleurs et bah
c'est là queemel Faber c'est là que les
standard américain ont fait un un un une
stratégie un petit peu maligne c'est
qu'ils ont embauché à la tête de leur
agence Emmanuel Faber que nous on
connaît bien en France parce que c'était
l'ex-patron très médiatisé de Danon et
récemment il s'est fendu d'une tribune
assassine qui pointait du doigt les
manquements de la CSRD donc du règlement
européen pour dire que celui qu'il
dirigeait maintenant à rebour de ses
positions précédentes en tant que chef
de Danon était bien meilleur donc il y a
une vraie question là derrière qui peut
paraître un peu technique mais qui en
fait une situation qui concerne tout le
monde parce que c'est pas un débat sur
les normes comptables sur une quelque
chose un petit peu hors sol c'est
quelque chose qui concerne tout le monde
aujourd'hui on parle d'un débat sur le
rôle des grandes entreprises et le rôle
qu'elles prendront pour la
transformation écologique elles sont un
peu face à un choix est-ce qu'on décide
de dire que les entreprises fonctionnent
toujours selon les règles du 20e siècle
donc elles pourront on se cacher vers
des défayances de marché ou vers le fait
qu'elles ne peuvent pas tout où est-ce
qu'elles contribuent aux règles du 21e
siècle en assumant leurs responsabilités
et en prenant les devant passionnant
merci beaucoup je peux vous dire que
dans les grands cabinets d'audit on
recrute
justement expertise et très recherché
Merci à VOUS Léa on passe à Mariette
vous vouliez Mariette d'iggrand revenir
sur un mot au cœur évidemment de
l'actualité internationale qui fait
partie de notre vocabulaire habituel ce
mot c'est le mot otage oui mirriam
d'habitude le mot otage nous n'hésitons
pas à l'employer dans le discours
médiatique classique par exemple quand
il y a une grève dans les transports les
Français sont autage des grévistes ou
bien j'ai entendu cette semaine que le
PS ne voulait plus être a Tage de
laanupè par exemple bon tout ça c'est la
métaphore et il est bien clair que
l'actualité internationale tragique en
ce moment nous empêche hein d'utiliser
cette image ça serait complètement
indécent et du coup nous oblige à
regarder l'origine même du terme donc
c'est là-dessus que je voudrais
réfléchir avec vous parce que cette
origine est extrêmement ancienne on est
vraiment dans le dans toutes les
cultures et et à l'origine des cultures
hein la Haute Égypte la Grèce antique et
cetera c'est-à-dire qu'en fait prendre
des otages est un acte
prédplomatique extrêmement archaïque
première chose deuxième chose quand on
regarde l'origine du mot dans le
français le latin et cetera c'est tout à
fait intéressant parce qu'on a deux
étymologies et vous allez voir que c'est
intéressant de les frotter l'une à
l'autre la première le motutage vient de
hostesse en latin on a en anglais
hostage c'est l'ôte c'est-à-dire que
l'ôutage c'est la personne qui va chez
quelqu'un qu' qu'il veut convaincre ou
vous êtes envoyé par votre roi et vous
êtes un comment dire la garantie la
preuve qu'il a de bonnes intentions même
si c'est vis-à-vis de son adversaire
donc l'otage est appelé otage de
souveraineté et puis il reste dans la
maison de celui qu'il veut convaincre 2è
étymologie c'est OSB en latin
c'est-à-dire le gage alors là c'est la
monnaie d'échange hm hm là l'otage est
complètement chosifié donc tout à
l'heure on avait la souveraineté et là
on a la matérialité absolue et donc
c'est cette dimension qui reste
aujourd'hui la dernière ces dernières
années on pourrait dire tout au long du
20e siècle il y a eu beaucoup de prises
d'otage mais bien sûr l'otage est une
chose que l'on marchandise en que que
l'on marchande mais il me semble que
dans la séquence actuelle aussi
dramatique soit-elle c'est comme si la
première étymologie repointé un peu son
NZ je m'explique quand les les les
familles des otages israéliens on mon é
leur visage leur nom et on fait émerger
via les réseaux sociaux qui pour une
fois avaient une dimension d'intimité je
trouve intéressante on fait émerger des
histoires hein des biographies des
familles et cetera il redeviennent
sujets et non plus objet c'est aussi
parce qu'il y a des enfants peut-être
par oui je pense que c'est un phénomène
un fait majeur he dans dans l'histoire
les enfants sont là donc dans la société
occidentale et bien les les familles
sont importantes les parents ont un rôle
clé on va voir mais j'ai pensé par
analogie si vous voulez myiam à quelque
chose qui est dans notre histoire à nous
histoire française 18e
siècle 40 ans avant la prise de la
Bastille il y a déjà une première prise
de la Bastille par des parents
figurez-vous c'est ce que raconte
arlette Farge l'historienne du de la vie
intime du 18e et elle raconte que vous
savez les enfants n'allaient pas à
l'école donc ils étaient dans les rues
de Paris il fais un peu n'importe quoi
ils se baignaient dans la scène il
chapardaient il criaent beaucoup il
faisait beaucoup de bruit et pour cette
raison bah des riverins agacés les ont
fait embastiller et là bah on pouvait
croire les commissaires politiques
pensai que ça passerait comme ça et pas
du tout les parents ont fait des
manifestations devant la Bastille
plusieurs jours plusieurs nuits et ils
ont fait libérer leurs enfants et Harlet
Farge dit que là il faut voir dans cette
dans ce moment-là et ben une sorte de
d'étape vers la la prise de pouvoir par
la société civile de quelque chose voilà
alors ça vaut ce que ça vautant mais je
me dis raison petite raison d'espérer
dans ce monde sinistre peut-être que la
société civile parfois a l'énergie de
soulever des montagnes h peut-être on
l'espère fortement le talent de Mariette
moi ça j'en suis ravi parce que je suis
au première loge t les tous les
vendredis je mesure mon privilège et dès
la semaine prochaine je serai de nouveau
à côté et je me réjou non ce qui est
intéressant je trouve pardon si j'ai une
seconde là-dessus c'est quand on fait
dérivver des termes le terme otage
effectivement c'est une criminalisation
de l'action quand on dit que la grve
prend en not
on voit bien à quel point la métaphore
est trompeuse de la même façon que nous
sommes en guerre quand il y a une vraie
guerre on voit bien qu'on était pas en
Guer il y a effectivement un retour du
réel sous la métaphore allez Thomas on
termine avec vous vous vouliez parler
business et musique ce so
effectivementam alors si vous écoutez ça
vous pensez à
[Musique]
qui exactement
bienam c'est signé c'est signéé facile
alors çae le plus grand groupe de rock
au monde et c'est impressionnant parce
que le chanteur Mick Jagger a fêté ses
80 ans les guitaristes k Richards et Ron
Wood s'en approchent aussi alors on a le
sexagagénère tom Cruise qui au cinéma
fait en ce moment des grimpettes
délirantes au cinéma eux ils ont 20 ans
de moins 20 ans de plus pardon et ils
affichent une forme olympique alors les
Stone c'est un peu la jeunesse éternelle
et le quotidien lescho a fait les
comptes cette semaine rien qu'en France
ils ont joué deux fois en 2022 une fois
en 2018 trois fois en 2017 une fois en
2014 et trois fois en 2012 grande forme
et on l'imagine avec pas mal de dollars
à la clé des recettes alors
effectivement il y a les concerts il y a
les albums les droits d'auteur les
vêtements bien sûr d'ailleurs je vous ai
ramé un petit t-shirt Merriam ah oui je
suis je suis preneuse je suis fan c'est
une vraie cach machine alors on estime
qu'en 60 ans d'existence le groupe a
vendu entre 200 et 250 millions de
disques une tournée rapporte plus de 200
millions à chaque fois un demi milliard
d'euros faut se rendre compte de des
proportions les fans viennent en masse
et il paye le prix évidemment c'est
entre 150 et 500 € la place en fait les
Rolling Stones c'est devenu une marque
commerciale c'est un peu la première qui
nous vient à l'esprit quand on pense au
rock un peu comme Nutella Pour les pâtes
à tartiné ou Haribo pour les bonbons
McDo pour les fast food c'est ce que les
économistes appellent la notoriété
spontanée alors justement comment ces
marques font pour ne jamais être
ringardisé alors ben en fait certaines
comme Nutella justement vont jouer
exprès sur ce créneau de la nostalgie ce
sont ce qu'on appelle des marques refuge
comme on parle de valeur refuge donc des
produits qui rassure par exemple Nutella
en 50 ans ils ont jamais changé de logo
jamais changé de packaging ou de recette
c'est totalement stable c'est un produit
intergénérationnel un peu comme les
chamallow de Haribo et ben les Stones
c'est un peu pareil leur longévité a
quelque chose de réconfortant de
sympathique surtout dans ces temps
troublés et les fans ils emmènent leurs
enfants au concert finalement la passion
se transmet de génération en génération
et enfin les Stones ont un atout de
taille que n'a pas nutella ou que n'a
pas haribo c'est qu'ils sont mortels ah
oui c'est un atout ça comment ça d'êre
mortel alors pourquoi est-ce que les
fans se ruent sur les places à chaque
concert parce qu'ils craignent que ce
soit leur dernier dernière tournée celle
qui va rester dans les anales et celle
pour laquelle ils pourront dire j é
exactement la même chose pour Johnny
ALID en France cette insertitude qui
pèse sur la longévité du groupe c'est
une forme de rareté et c'est une règle
qu'on connaît bien en économie ce qui
est rare et cher bref lesestone c'est un
business model imparable qu'on peut
résumer en un mot safaction bravo quelle
chute vous les avez vu sur scène
Bertrand
Perri prendre billet assez rapidement
cont
tenu absolument absolument merci
finiment moi je les ai vu sur scène il y
a longtemps il y avait des poupées
gonflables incroyables je veux le
t-shirt ou le pin merci beaucoup ça va
si c'est médium c'est bon le dernier
album est sorti ce soir pour tous les
fans merci les affanchis merci Léa Falco
à vendredi prochain et Merci à VOUS
Bertrand la parole pour le meilleur et
pour le pire de Cicéron à chat GPT c'est
à lire chez Jean-Claude latè c'est le
weekend profitez bien merci à toutes les
équipes d' LCP derrière la caméra qui
m'ont permis à nouveau de vous proposer
une très belle semaine d'émission très
belle soirée à très
vite